foreign
[Music]
French is a name famous you might say
Infamous among conservative media Types
on Twitter though largely unknown
outside of that admittedly somewhat
insular Circle French is one of those
self-professed reasonable and principled
conservative pundits who proves his
reasonableness by focusing his criticism
almost entirely to the right he likes to
focus especially on attacking what he
views as far-right extremist
evangelicals he believes that the
biggest problem in the Christian church
is that Christians are two militant and
too right-wing which is to say that
David French is just based on that alone
totally clueless Because the actual
problem in the church is quite the
opposite of that but up until this point
French had not spent much time
applying his brand of cluelessness to
the debates over gender ideology
which is a rather noticeable evasion
especially because he lives I believe in
Tennessee yet he has said nothing about
the Vanderbilt Scandal and still has
said nothing about it actually but he
has finally chimed in on the broader
topic and what he had to say is somehow
even more vapid and incoherent than I
even expected so I'm going to read from
his piece on the dispatch and he begins
with what seems to be an encouraging
note he says this
I'm a person who believes in the
traditional Christian doctrines of
marriage and sexual morality I don't
believe in sex outside of marriage
between a man and a woman I don't agree
that um uh trans men are are men or that
trans women are women and while I strive
to treat every person I encounter with
dignity and respect I don't use
preferred pronouns because their use is
a form of ascent to a system of belief
to which I do not subscribe
so I will say that David French not
using preferred pronouns is a curveball
that I didn't see coming maybe I
misjudged the man or maybe not because
he continues
that makes me pretty far right correct
well not when the right gets
authoritarian or closes its mind and
heart to the legacy of real Injustice
oh well see there's the David French we
know and love he goes on to rightly
condemn California for its recent
legislation making itself a sanctuary
State quote unquote for child sex change
operations it's a place where minors can
now come and be mutilated and sterilized
without parental consent French says
that that's wrong
and he's right that it is wrong
but of course he can't just leave it
there now comes the classic David French
false moral equivalence he says this
this wouldn't be 2022 if the story ran
only one way just as California has
escalated the culture wars by
potentially severing the parent-child
relationship when parents object to
various methods of gender reassignment
Texas now threatens to break families
when parents consent to those same
treatments in February Texas Attorney
General Ken Paxton wrote to Texas
representative Matt Krause and argued
that certain sex change or gender
reassignment procedures including
various surgical procedures and the
prescriptions of puberty blockers can
legally constitute child abuse under
several provisions of Texas law the
Texas directives and DCPS dfps
investigations are currently subject to
litigation and I have little doubt the
California will face its own lawsuits
but this is where we are now it's not
enough to disagree over important
matters now the culture War requires a
direct attack on the most fundamental
American Liberty interests
okay but how is protecting children from
a grotesque physical and sexual abuse a
direct attack on Liberty whose Liberty
is being attacked the abusers I mean is
he worried about the abuser's Liberty
well yes precisely reading on it says in
an ex in an excellent comprehensive
piece at public discourse Catholic
University Professor Melissa mocella
outlines the stakes well after outlining
the risks and side effects of popular
gender affirming measures like puberty
blockers she writes quote it is clearly
untenable to claim that parents who are
hesitant to rush their children into
risky controversial Medical Treatments
of unproven efficacy are guilty of
medical neglect but that's not the
entire story a similar admonition
applies to the right again here's
mostella given current divisions and
medical opinion loving and responsible
parents may be convinced that such
treatments are necessary for the child's
health thus it is clearly within the
parents sphere of constitutionally
protected child-rearing authority to
seek a legal medical treatment for their
child following the advice of the
child's doctors
and French agrees with mostella saying
quote yet as serious as the
Constitutional deprivations are outside
of criminal law it is difficult to think
of an exercise of state power more raw
immediate and devastating than the use
of state power to sever the bond between
parent and child it is a power to be
exercised sparingly in the most extreme
cases it's not a power to enlist in the
culture War over one of the emotional
and contentious contests of our time at
a time of profound public Division and
deep moral conflict pluralism suffers
from a serious disadvantage compared to
the illiberal e-liberal extremes of far
right and far left States should pass
age restrictions prohibiting dramatic
medical interventions for children at an
absolute minimum they must require
parental consent but they can express
their values and pass the regulations
while still remembering a singular moral
and constitutional command
leave loving families alone
okay
so we must congratulate Mr French I mean
he noticed how the left has staked out
uh an incoherent and morally insane
position on this topic and he endeavored
to one-up them by adopting a position
even more incoherent and morally insane
and he succeeded in his goal Against All
Odds he succeeded
it's bad enough to argue that some
little girls are actually boys inside
and need to be surgically and medically
altered to turn them into their true
selves
it's even worse to acknowledge that all
of that is nonsense
and yet defend a parent's right to
mutilate their children anyway so French
as he says knows that boys aren't girls
and yet is now willing to call it is not
is not willing to call it child abuse
when a parent has a boy physically and
permanently damaged in order to make him
into what he isn't and can never be
you know a mom who throws her son out
the window because she thinks that he's
really a bird
is dangerous and psychotic obviously
but the sane man who sits by and watches
it happen and even defends the mother's
right to do it
is something even worse I would say
so contrary to what French claims leave
loving families alone
is neither a constitutional nor moral
command it is rather the platitude of
the intellectually lazy
you know I would say that
a parent who permanently disfigures
their children and sets them up for a
lifetime of confusion Despair and regret
are not by any definition of the term
loving because to love is to will the
good of the other and castrating and
sterilizing your children is not willing
their good but rather willing their
misery and their eventual suicide and
it's not just my subjective opinion that
it isn't good to do this to a child it's
a moral fact
it is so fundamental so basic so
self-evident that to deny it is to
invalidate any and all moral statements
because if we cannot say that it is
plainly evil to castrate and mutilate
children then we cannot say that
anything is evil I cannot think of a
definition of evil that would not
include to start with this form of abuse
and besides even if this abuse does
align with a parent's perverted idea of
love so what
not everything done in the Name of Love
is okay or moral nor should it all be
permissible under the law just because
someone said it was loving obviously
here David I will uh I'll tell you a
singular moral command here's one
protect the innocent
children are innocent
and they
cannot consent to being brutalized in
this way they cannot consent to it it is
happening to them it is happening to
their bodies their lives they cannot
consent
who gives a damn if the parent consents
to it what does that matter
the fact that their parent consents to
it is irrelevant
and will do the child no good as he
grows older
when a young girl enters adulthood
without her breasts without her voice
without her ability to have children all
of that permanently deprived of her
taken away stolen
what difference does the parents
previous consent make
who cares is she supposed to take solace
in that while she's forced to live every
day for the rest of her life with the
tattered remains of her Womanhood
is she gonna live the next
six Decades of her life saying well at
least my parents consented to it when I
was 14.
if you're so focused on rights
why not focus on the right of a child to
be free from grave bodily harm
does a child have that right David does
a child not have that god-given right
what about a child's right to their own
body their own identity their own future
let me ask you this do parents have the
right to mutilate their children
or do children have the right to not be
mutilated
that is the central question that is the
question right there
and one with an obvious answer if you
ask me
it's it's the most obvious and the
easiest answer imaginable
yet it's an answer that you still fail
to get right
which is amazing
and even worse you know better
and you admit that you know better
and for that reason David French is
today canceled and we'll leave it there
for this portion of the show as we move
over into the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]